so the crazy thing right now you know as
we're talking about this somehow the
Democrats blocked the the emergency bill
again I can't believe that well - you
told me that I was like what it's it's
it's not the same as like on Monday they
voted they voted to stop it which is a
hard block on Tuesday they voted to stop
it hard block
yeah today they just didn't vote on it
like even though in the Senate they did
so I don't want to get too political but
when you look at this story from the
Washington Post which is it's it's from
today it's it's actually from only a
couple hours ago where we're actually
entertaining the conversation where
doctors will not try to save you and we
and we have time so many people on
Twitter are saying things like the
stimulus bill isn't enough money for me
to pay my rent I don't care you're
getting something you're getting four
months of guaranteed wages from the
federal government this is unprecedented
and they want to get money to hospitals
in states Governor Cuomo said not enough
we need ten times as much it's like
we'll take this for now let's push this
through as fast as we can right and then
maybe we'll do something I don't know
I don't know I didn't write the bill
there's profit you know the some
Republicans are now are saying it's got
some bad stuff in it all I know is I
think our country is panicking yeah I
think for as much as you know what I
think
I'll tell I'll tell you what Donald
Trump's approval rating is gonna go
ninety-nine hundred percent because as
things get crazier and scarier and
scarier people are gonna say shut up I
don't care anymore save my family
save us when I look out when I go to the
TV and I see when I when I saw what I
saw today in Congress that freaked me
out
I was I was dumbfounded right they were
only open for like a minute a minute
yeah it's called the pro forma because
they're not allowed to skip sessions a
certain number of times like three days
in a row okay so they apparently went in
banged it walked out so it didn't didn't
consider it it still considered a
session and it was it was fir it was
from at 10 a.m. and 42 seconds until
10:00 a 1002 and 17 senators home like
that like a minute and 20 seconds
iterative session because they were in
there they said no business how many
people were in there
no I don't know this was just was
reported by Politico but here's the
thing when you turn on the TV
Trump's doing his daily press briefings
yeah everything he's saying we have hope
and what's the press doing
there's knocking him like crazy yeah
there so what is the press what is their
goal what is their goal because no idea
because if he's trying to give everyone
hope and they're saying he's lying he's
lying it's like so what you don't want
us to hope you don't want do a general
public telling they litter there's a
chance we can come out of this like
there is their point
CNN wrote a story that said Trump
peddles unsubstantiated hope it doesn't
make any sense
listen I don't understand the media man
I mean it's it's clicks it's money it's
rage bait rage I hope I hope at least
coming out of this which I think will
come out of this people will learn to
not care and start and start new news
according to a CBS poll rate listen
according to a CBS poll the American
people now trust Donald Trump more than
national media that was it I'm like I'm
too mad like telling people like two
three years ago four years ago when he
was running for president it's like
there's gonna be a day that you trust
him more than the news everyone's gonna
be like no no but you know here we are
you know it is I think I think it's for
one his uh his his TV ratings his press
pre press briefings just broke 12.2
million views more than Monday Night
Football
Wow this story there is no Monday Night
Football so people are kind of itching
for something well the the Nielsen
ratings said it's Monday Night Football
ratings that's right compared to like
rivaling the bachelor season finale
massive so you have we have a Bachelor
of that good no no no do you you know
like don't ever seen The Bachelor I
don't know a thing about it
you know like a Big Bang Theory gets 20
million viewers right are you serious
yes I've only seen one episode and I
wasn't I didn't laugh yeah I was just
like angry watching yes yeah so here's
what I think I think is happening right
we have these stories like the one in
The Washington Post about hospitals
basically saying you know do not
resuscitate we're gonna we're gonna
choose to let you go or something yeah
and then that's scary
it's getting really scary yes and the
economy is tanking rent is due
people can't skip these paychecks and so
they're looking for answers as things
get bad they turn on the TV and there's
Trump
there's dr. foul chi people trust foul
Chi more than double than that of Trump
it's something like 80 some odd percent
trust dr. foul Chi and 44 Trust chump
Trump what so what's so big about this
he's a scientist is that why he's a
doctor he's all right and I think he cut
he handled specifically infectious
disease okay so here's what people see
on January 29th Trump formed this task
force yeah Democrats are trying to
impeach him on the 31st he imposed
travel restrictions yep
now you can criticize him all day for
downplaying the severity of this early
on everyone was Biden called him a
xenophobe yeah he said yep xenophobic
travel restrictions and I watched that
the interview with Biden and the some
reporter and it was just embarrassing he
tried to flip it dude I feel like I know
what happened
you are trying to flip it right now and
it's not working bro I think eyes
doesn't he's cringy man I'm starting to
feel like you know there was a big
market rally today so maybe maybe where
things might turn around a little bit
hopefully things don't get worse but
this story from the Washington Post is
really alarming but I think you know I
was exaggerating when I said Trump will
hit like a hundred percent I think it's
gonna go up a lot because he is into 120
percent no but maybe like 70 yeah
because there's gonna surprise me yeah
right now his approval rating for the
handling of the corona virus outbreak is
60% according to Gallup Wow and gallops
a trustworthy you know eyelet if you
look at the past four well above water
55 56 58 you know and the gallop was the
biggest a 22-point you know pull ahead
and and here's what here's what I want
to get to here's the point I wanna make
when you look at Congress the Democrats
and the Republicans negotiate all
weekend calm will come up to come into
an agreement
come Monday Nancy Pelosi steps in
Democrats say no everyone's shot
come Tuesday they vote we're not gonna
vote on they vote it down blocked again
everyone's shocked all night they
negotiate at 1:00 in the morning the
Democrats and Republicans announced they
had an agreement they were celebrating
that's that's really amazing
I did I was the first I recorded I was
like this really cool I was like I'm
glad that they got it done and I'm not
gonna sit here and rag on the Democrats
they got some they got some gains they
negotiated Republicans gave a little
space yeah increase the number in some
areas congratulations everybody we got
it done for America yeah and then Pelosi
was like no vote and so what I see there
is you know I was asking a friend I
couldn't believe it I had to I had to
ask someone else like am I seeing this
is this really happening yeah and what
he said was Nancy Pelosi and the
Democrats can't control the presses
because they will absolutely say no
because they don't they don't care so
you have the you know the Republicans
and Democrats in Congress finally saying
ok ok this works for us and let's get it
done let's get it done fast they're like
oh they're giving us some leeway we got
to use this well yes
squeeze them for more they want
environmental provisions like Nancy
Pelosi's bill that is a stimulus package
right to help American people I'm just
clarifying it just for my own like yeah
that's it right ok so but but the issue
here I'm not trying to make it super
political the issue is just that the
Democrats are fractured they don't agree
with you generally right if the
Democrats in the Senate say this we're
good on this we negotiate it and we're
happy then why won't the House Democrats
be like all right we're good to go
because they're not a unified party so
then when you turn the TV and you're
looking for answers and you're seeing
nothing but chaos in Congress yeah you
then see the president you see the
people all around him and he's saying
things like this medication has been
promising he actually said it might work
it might not I'm hopeful I think it'll
work we're gonna we're gonna try and
push this one through and do what we can
ya know and then he got attacked for it
yeah and then you know that's the woman
whose husband died fish cleaner fish and
they blame it as an intestinal look as
far as I'm concerned and they're running
with that story I still see stuff today
about it's like are you kidding me
you're still running with the story it's
so bad the New York Times here's how
many logic would would see right through
that
here's how they launder information the
New York Times wrote a story about
Trump's ratings going through the roof
and his approval ratings going through
the roof and in it they passively say
Trump has been heavily criticized for
encouraging people to consume a
dangerous product or a product that is
unproven to help which resulted in a man
dying after ingesting a similar comment
they slipped that in there yep and now
that New York Times story becomes
historical reference it goes on
Wikipedia goes in encyclopedias and they
say Trump did it it's like dude the guy
never said to take powdered fish
antiparasitics and put it in your drink
and you think it I know it's insane
and it's like exactly it's ridiculous
these people are crazy
long story short the point I was trying
to get to with this past you know bit is
that I don't want to be I don't know
what doomsayer but these past few
stories I've been reading it does not
sound good
I've tried to be optimistic and say like
hey you know like the markets rallying
is good news but you look at what's
happening in some other countries and
there's a bit of good news but I think
China's lying because that you see that
you see these videos that are
circulating and their recent ones don't
believe them
like I don't believe what China's saying
I see these videos and it's like yeah
they're saying that no more infections
yeah they were on that steep uphill
climb then they're like oh we're done we
figured it out we figured it out we just
won't tell anybody but we're still gonna
common to your exports yeah I'm not
gonna give you those masks you need yeah
so I don't I don't know here's what
here's what I'm here's what's worrying
to me it looks like with today watching
how the Democrats handle things yeah it
seems like our government is in a panic
it's disarray oh yeah I agree except for
Trump who's not meld together but I'm
not saying he's like a steadfast
vigilant soldier he's just less panicky
and spazzy than the rest of them yeah
you know like he's actually coming out
saying here's what I do it's like okay
you know a lot of those a lot of the
Congress men and women are in a
comfortable bubble and that bubble is
being popped right now because they're
susceptible a lot of them are older you
know and you got all these stupid young
people running around doing stuff like
spreading it around there's a lizard
let's actually do this let's let's just
show some of these stories
yeah so the first one I want to show is
Washington State football player Brice
Beekman found dead at 22 after
experiencing breathing problems as the
school remains closed due to coronavirus
this in no way has anything to do with
coronavirus oh the headline just put
that in there everyone is locked down
everyone is locked down yeah yeah
someone someone was saying to us
yesterday that or maybe the other day
that her friends grandma passed away and
they just there's any death that's
happening right now
there no that's that story what was that
that's another that's another fake text
me oh it was yep I have heard that exact
same story really my friend said that
you know their grandma and I've heard
the exact same thing from my 10 people
now okay no good to know yeah yeah so I
don't know maybe this one that's this
one about done so this is just the media
taking advantage now it's possible this
dude did have coronavirus okay because
there have been a lot of videos coming
out some of these other countries where
somebody will be walking and ison
they'll just collapse because they
didn't realize how sick they were there
so there are stories about people who
felt fine and then within an hour head
of crazy fever and shortness of breath
and we're like wheezing yeah it's
possible he didn't know and but I think
what they're doing here is trying to
karna virus whoo oh look he died uh no
click on me right click on this link
however yeah there are stories yeah
21:21 euros a 17 year old now there's a
different story but a 17 year old died
the locals are saying yes it was
coronavirus and go state officials are
saying no no no wait wait wait we don't
know for sure we don't know for sure oh
who knows for sure I don't know but we
have this one at least so this is a 21
what 21 year old woman reportedly died
of the corona virus in UK and is
believed to be the youngest person in
the country with no underlying health
conditions to succumb to the bug the
family of Buckinghamshire resident Chloe
Milton posted the grim news Tuesday on
Facebook according to local media to all
the people out there that thinks thinks
it's just a virus please think again
speaking from a personal from personal
experience this so-called virus had
taken a life of my 21 year old daughter
said her mom died in Middleton Chloe's
aunt and
mr. e also posted about the young girls
kovat 19 related death on Facebook and
noted that her beautiful and
kind-hearted niece had no underlying
health issues my loved ones are going
through the most unimaginable pain
we are shattered beyond belief the
reality of this virus is only just
unfolding before our very eyes
please please adhere to government
guidelines do your bit protect yourself
and protect others the virus isn't
spreading people are spreading the virus
to relative added yeah the post went on
to say life as we know it has changed
dramatically but unless we all act now
to protect ourselves and others the
longer this turmoil and anguish will go
on the UK's youngest victim is an 18
year old with significant underlying
health issues who died in Coventry West
Midlands after contracting kovat 19 but
the virus was not said to be his direct
cause of death so there's they're
similar stories they're calling them
like Kovac Kovac complications
yeah or complications related to to
Kovac well I think okay so that's one
where do you have check this one out
New Jersey athlete 25 who works at Bank
of America is in an induced coma after
doctors lost his coronavirus test
results as his mom slams NBA players for
being tested before her very sick son
look man there's gonna be a lot of you
know progressive lefties saying the
system is broken
rich people are getting tests there was
a viral viral tweet where someone said
the easiest way to get tested for corona
virus is to coughin the face of a rich
person and wait for their results to
come back because it is it's celebrities
and athletes who are just snapping their
fingers and getting tested when they
want it it's true now I can understand
the politicians you know right that's a
little bit different but Ryan Reynolds
said it best we all know the people are
gonna get through the celebrities well I
love it after ping-pong players yeah
that's great and 400 other yeah I gotta
admit it is it is crazy to hear all
these stories and not really be
experiencing it you know it's like
surreal and that's why I think a lot of
people defer to conspiracy theories yeah
so easily online people are saying this
is this can't be real
I don't know anybody who's affected by
this haven't seen anybody exactly it's
like I don't know anybody has the flu
I don't do you know but
we gotta stop comparing to the flu
anyway right right but what I mean is
like are you also going to say I don't
know anybody who has the coal a cold
right now well well that's right right
I'm saying it's like so it looks like
we're dealing with something really
serious and a lot of people have been
downplaying it in a rather I guess
unfortunate way
yeah Cavalier and man I can only go back
to thinking like if we didn't if we
don't have these hospital beds how much
higher with them will the mortality rate
get and will young people be affected by
it yeah right
so one of the things they've been doing
is putting people in induced comas
actually let's let's read try and figure
out maybe they'll maybe will say why
they say 25 year old New Jersey man is
fighting for his life in an induced coma
after doctors lost his coronavirus test
results that confirmed he had the deadly
virus okay well what do you mean they
they lost it lost it but they now armed
okay well then we know okay he has been
in a ventilator in a medically induced
coma for six days at a hospital and
Edison Allard who is an all-american
lacrosse player and works at the Bank of
America and Manhattan first became sick
on March 13th
he was suffering from a high fever back
pain had been throwing up allard
initially didn't present as a typical
coronavirus patient given his age that
he had no pre-existing conditions and
the fact he hadn't traveled overseas
recently his mother Jenny elder told ABC
news of the lab that was processing his
co vat19 test results somehow lost the
sample she said it's setback his
treatment about five days
oh so that's what they're trying to say
so it was confirmed they didn't have it
so he couldn't get treated for it due to
the delay in returning a positive test
he wasn't allowed access to potentially
life-saving experimental drugs oh yeah
Cuomo is saying exactly what Trump said
hydroxychloroquine does it throw Meissen
and and other you know were they call
exact throw max or something as if
they're Max and I think that the brand
name is like Scyther mentioned something
okay but then you have some like
governor I think it's Nevada banning it
don't even know it's going on banning
the medicine yeah itself yeah you're
saying you can't you can't be treated
for it probably because you know what
man
because some stupid person drink some
fish probably whatever because the media
has got this claim over it was Trump's
fault that someone drank
pair anti-parasitic people are so stupid
so they say that his mother has since
slammed health officials giving NBA
players you know access to tests but not
his but his sons being bungled she said
my son is healthy no pre-existing
conditions and he's 25 this virus is
really dangerous and now he is very very
sick I want to say something I want to
imagine this crisis like tsunami imagine
you're standing in the middle of the
street and a bunch of people start
running and screaming past you and
you're standing there going like what's
going on why is everyone running and
they say there's a tsunami coming run
and you go I don't know about that I
can't I guess it's seen yeah you guys
run something's not right
none of my friends are running yeah and
then 10 minutes later you're standing
there going like see no soon oh man
there's the tsunami and you're done this
is the challenge I understand why people
are skeptical of all this because you
know part of me in the back of my head
I'm like can this really be happening
like optimism boss I can't believe it
you know what man I don't think all of
these super wealthy global elites who
are trying to form this big economic
bloc in Europe would sacrifice decades
of their vision for this like what what
Germany and Austria and France are doing
shutting down their Boers essentially
undermining the entirety of the European
Union they've been trying to put
together for decades I don't know if I
believe they would want to do that right
let alone all these companies like
giving up billions upon billions of
dollars politicians I I just like like
Rand Paul is in on it sorry dude I buy
it man
no no no I don't believe it you know hey
every every time I see this someone's
dying I want to know more information
you know are they smokers right are they
vegan I do this guys and I know that's a
random sidebar but have you seen game
changers I don't know if anyone has seen
game changers but it's a it's
specifically about what animal protein
does to the blood and how it it lessens
the ability to have the body move oxygen
through the body it clouds the blood up
so that oxygen doesn't get around as
easily so so if that's the case then I'd
be curious why this hasn't happened
earlier what hasn't
I roll attack like this what do you mean
it was 100 years ago
yeah nothing's changed in the way we eat
dude well I mean it you know I think it
could have happened at any point yeah
you know it doesn't matter when as a
matter of it
well here's the thing listen listen you
bring up a really good just like here is
I want to know more information about
everyone that's dying right I want to
know all of the information you know
like I think you bring up a good point
about lying health issues it's like look
yeah but what is considered an
underlying health issue doesn't you know
this dude's an athlete yeah I know Rasta
Jack lees I really I really doubt he
smokes right I'm not I'm not getting
this vibe like he if he's La Crosse's
your running back and forth yeah you've
got to have healthy lungs to run back
and forth so it's like it can't just it
can't just be that you know it's it's
obviously had healthy lungs if he's a
star it said right and he's a all-star
lacrosse player like those people run
non-stop lacrosse is a heavy running
sport all-american lacrosse player yeah
I don't know that means I know lacrosse
is a legit you know taxing sport yeah
it's a hard sport I think I think you're
bringing up a good point about general
scientific research on diets and
illnesses for yeah I agree but that's
what I'm trying to say yeah but that
that's like a longer conversation about
collecting the data and then down the
road looking at stuff yeah this to me
sounds like it's worse than the Spanish
flu yeah well I don't know much about
the Spanish the Spanish flu was a novel
virus okay with a mortality rate of 2.5%
isn't that right we're we're at a lower
barrier now well so in the u.s. were but
we're below I believe one what it will
ya 1.8 believe though we're really is
3.4 so so actually look no no we're what
are we we have fifty nine thousand nine
hundred eighty-six total cases in 823
deaths I don't necessarily think it
makes sense to calculate current
infected to current dead because you'd
think the closed cases do you recover or
do you die yeah in that case Italy is
scary yes it's like 40 percent yeah so
if you look at closed cases you got a
sixteen percent mortality rate for
closed cases yeah and and the fact that
you can you can get it again right so
that's been a few was over it's now been
reported
another time Brian so it was initially
reported in Japan that there was
reinfection and then it was reported
again China may be seeing a potential
reinfection yeah the other issue is
mutation so one story that's been going
around is that it's not mutating fast
enough so that one vaccine may be made
just deal with it I hope so yeah me too
but then I read another article that
saying there's more than 20 different
mutations that someone's found and and
two different ones in the same in the
same body yeah so this is what this is
what's crazy look at this what a week
ago we are at what like a few thousand
people infected is what exponential
growth looks like I think here I think
New York is in is in serious serious
trouble yeah and you know that there's
man the census is right now the 2020
census is now people are fleeing the
city this is gonna dramatically change
the face of our economy our politics
I've seen really sad posts of like
businesses going under family businesses
that were like around for 40 years
saying like this is it yeah we were out
of money we can't do it
no business we can't pay anybody we're
laying off or shutting down rent is due
in six days yeah here we go
things are gonna get crazy yeah what's
gonna happen right I'll tell you what's
gonna happen the authoritarian lockdown
is coming yeah the government is gonna
step in and they're gonna take over and
they're gonna say you know it's gonna
here's gonna happen you will beg the
government to step in thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you